[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi sono portato lo sgabello da
solo Ciao come
va Eh bugiardi Vabbè e diciamo siamo
tutti qui a parlare di disagio quindi
poteva andare meglio E io sono Salvo
sono molto contento di di essere qui e
onestamente sono terrorizzato da questa
cosa e quando mi hanno chiesto appunto
di fare questa roba del Ted Talk che è
una roba rispetto molto mi mi chiedevo
come mai
eh avessero chiamato me e poi ho letto
che il tema era per l'appunto il disagio
ho detto ci sta
eho l'amministratore italiano del
disagio Quindi ci sta e e onestamente
non non sapevo bene come approcciare
questa cosa qui perché so che
tendenzialmente è sempre tutto
incentrato sul sull'ispirazione no sul
dare delle lezioni Io onestamente non ho
niente da insegnare a nessuno e quando
ho parlato poi con l'organizzazione loro
mi' hanno detto Io ho detto ma di
preciso che cosa vi aspettate loro mi
hanno detto ma ti volevo tre prima della
pausa per avere un momento di leggerezza
G ho detto vabbè volevate un pagliaccio
ho detto Sì vogliamo un pagliaccio
Eccomi qua e al posto dei palloncini ho
storielle
buffe però siccome ci tengo a fare
Potrebbe essere l'ultimo che faccio
Quindi volevo fare la full
Esatto la full Experience Ho preparato
delle slide ma poiché non ho niente di
interessante da
dire sono tutte gattini
Cioè questo è particolarmente carino Tra
l'altro Ma di cosa parleremo oggi volevo
fare con voi un viaggetto attraverso
quello che è il mio altrove in questa
parte della mia vita che è questa cosa
appunto della standup Comedy che faccio
da relativamente poco un paio di
anni intanto partiamo con una domanda
chissà cos'è la standup Comedy alzata di
mano 17 persone va alla grande questa
questa forma di intrattenimento stand
comedi è battute ok e inso comici su un
palco tendenzialmente in piedi
tendenzialmente con uno sgabello che io
ho portato proprio per onorare questa
arte
e dove la cosa più bella è la libertà
d'espressione un pochettino la
possibilità di dire un po' quello che ti
pare e per me è stato tipo una un amore
che ho scoperto quando avevo Boh 14-1
anni andavo al liceo scopro questi
comici americani che dicono un po'
quello che gli pare e e quando sei
adolescente arrabbiato È fighissimo
vedere della gente che dice quello che
pensa su un palco arrabbiatissimo dice
Oh mio Dio dice le parolacce no questa
cosa qui è stupendo Quindi decido forse
io un giorno voglio fare questa cosa qui
e non la faccio per tipo 10 anni
continuo ad accumulare appunti da
persona arrabbiata finché a un certo
punto
arriva il
covid arriva il covid c'era un po'
questa paura no dopo che siamo usciti
dal lockdown di di poterci tornare
dentro e quindi dico forse è il momento
di provare a fare questa roba qui mi
faccio iscrivere a un Open Mic GL Open
farò un sacco userò un sacco di parole
del gergo in questo Quindi se qualcuno
signore lei sa cos'è un openmic Che culo
e per chi non lo sapesse è tipo dove tu
vai a provare 10 minuti di battute per
vedere se funzionano col pubblico quindi
mi scrive al mio primo openmic vado a
guardare i miei appunti dell'adolescenza
ed erano robe atroci nulla faceva ridere
erano solo cose arrabbiate e e a un
certo punto io ho detto però io non sono
arrabbiato io sono triste e quindi ho
scritto un pezzettino di 8 minuti l'ho
provato la sera dopo ed è stato
bellissimo è stato fighissimo e il fatto
che la gente possa ridere per quello che
fa ridere anche a te la sensazione più
bella del mondo e ho detto facciamo
diventare un mestiere questa cosa qua Ed
è cominciato
questo
percorso che è stata una montagna russa
che mi ha portato fino a qui oggi
Perché hai questa primo Picco questa
prima fase in cui tutto è bellissimo Hai
20anni di vita alle spalle di aneddoti
super divertenti che non vedi l'ora di
condividere con un pubblico quindi io a
primi primi mesi che Camminavo per
strada mi tornava in mente una roba e
andavo correvo ad puntarmi
bellissimo due giorni diventava un pezzo
che faceva super ridere e va super bene
bene bene bene finché a un certo punto
non finisci gli aneddoti che raccontavi
a amici prima e lì sei abbastanza
inguaiato diciamo è abbastanza difficile
e c'è una frase molto bella che ha detto
Luis durante un'intervista buonanima
durante un'intervista
che è quando finisci parafrasando quando
finisci le battute sugli aeroporti e sul
traffico puoi solo guardarti dentro ok e
cercare le cose e io ho provato a fare
questa roba qui che è una cosa che di
solito non facciamo di solito le cosine
del di dentro le teniamo nel di
dentro ma in quel momento mi sembra la
cosa giusta da fare ho cominciato a
ravanare nelle Sensazioni brutte
e ho trovato una miniera d'oro di cose
di cui sentivo che volevo parlare no ed
è stato terribile e meraviglioso e
terribile
perché ti chiedi sempre quanto diretto
hai di condividere questa cosa con degli
sconosciuti perché poi di questo si
tratta la cosa matta della standup è che
sono io che parlo contro 100 di voi E
voi siete tendenzialmente persone
orribili No no no lo siete cioè Vedo
gente che annuisce sì lo
sono perché cioè gente giudicanti e dai
Facci ridere e sempre pronto a dire hai
sbagliato questo hai sbagliato quello ed
è terribile io cosa faccio vengo qui e
do impasto la mia esperienza di vita a
questi
sconosciuti ma è anche meraviglioso
Perché poi arrivi a un momento quando lo
fai
in cui ti
accorgi che questa distanza non esiste
perché stiamo tutti male è una roba
meravig perché quando cominci veramente
a dare alla gente questa cosa qui ti
accorgi che se dai il 100% ricevi il
100% e ti accorgi che abbiamo avuto
tutti le stesse scuole medie tutti gli
stessi nonni tutti gli stessi padri
tutta la stessa esperienza ed è una
sensazione meravigliosa Questa sensazion
della condivisione cioè essere in una
stanza e avere paura delle stesse cose e
poterne parlare per 10 minuti 20 minuti
un'ora È meraviglioso e esci con
qualcosa Non non vi mentirò è anche
terribile Cioè ci sono le serate in cui
siamo tutti amici e le serate quando sei
a Santa Caterina villaermosa e diciamo
ci sono 4.000 anziani davanti a te e se
tu parli di dinosauri non c'è
esattamente quel feeling per cui io ho
avuto delle esperienze agghiaccianti
facendo questo lavoro una volta una
delle serate più importanti per me della
mia vita aprivo lo spettacolo aprivo E
facevo il numero 10 minuti prima dello
spettacolo di Luca
Ravenna
golat di Luca Ravenna e serata per me
super super
importante succede questa roba per cui
quando arriviamo lì e io Avo cominciato
da due mesi il tipo del del comune ci
accoglie e Ah Luca Ravenna Wow
Incredibile quello famoso poi viene da
me e tu sei Salvo Di Paola faccio Wow mi
conosce la Santa Caterina villaermosa
Sono famoso e e aggiunge ti chiami Come
il nostro assessore all'Urbanistica
detto grande Sì sono proprio io il suo
omonimo
E facevo questo pranzo con
l'amministrazione
e subito dopo quando loro vanno via e
Luca si gira verso di me e mi dice Tu
stasera andrai di
merda perché Beh perché anche io andrò
male perché nessuno andrà bene Stasera
me lo sento e faccio Grazie per queste
parole di conforto ho cominciato a due
mesi e ed è stato così è stato così è
stato agghiacciante ho fatto 8 minuti
nel Ho provato a rompere il ghiaccio con
quella cosa sull'assessore
all'Urbanistica
genio della comicità sono salito ho
fatto Ciao io sono di Paola ma non il
vostro assessore all'Urbanistica
silenzio uno sul fondo che dice è in
pensione fine
delle delle interazioni fra me e conella
gente completamente quindi ci sono dei I
momenti brutti di questo
mestiere sono delle spade nel diaframma
sono una roba atroce ok E sono quella
cosa di cioè il silenzio dopo una
battuta è il vero
altrove ok No non avete avete presente
quando fate una una battuta alla cena di
Natale e nessuno vi ha
sentito
moltiplicatori proprio quando è come
quando stai salendo le scale a un certo
punto pensi che c'è un gradino in più No
quella quella cosa lì è atroce ti tempra
ti tempra e va meglio di solito tende ad
andare
meglio ma quando invece va bene e riesce
a raggiungere quello Sweet Spot di
confidenza con il pubblico dove tu stai
sanguinando E loro lo sanno e ti danno
il sangue in cambio lì è Ah pasta al
forno Cioè una cosa buon Scusate per i
regionalismi
e una cosa incredibile e ti accorgi
anche che la gente ha una voglia matta
di parlare nel bene e nel male nel male
è il fatto che quando fai questo
mestiere e vai in giro a e a fare
battute e a volte succede che finisci lo
spettacolo e la gente pensa che tu sia
un Clown sempre qu quando in realtà tu
sei tipo in tour da due settimane hai
fatto tre pasti decenti ti sei fatto la
doccia una volta e mezzo sul Trenitalia
così e quindi sei lì e dice Quindi
adesso cosa fai per ci pigliamo una
birra e io no no no sono le 11:30 cioè
Lil grp devo andare
e nel bene invece è quando Io a volte a
me piace fare delle domande durante lo
spettacolo a volte anche un po' intime
dal che lavoro fai l'avvocato che schifo
Ahah e andiamo avanti Ha delle robe un
po' più
intim recentemente nell'ultimo
spettacolo Sto esplorando questa domanda
che vorrei porre anche a voi stasera
che Quanti di voi hanno hanno paura di
diventare come il proprio
padre
onestamente Ok ok Un po' di
persone
signora posso
Ciao Posso chiederle come
mai era
peso Eh si può fare Body shaming o sì No
mi dispiace cioè io speravo qualcosa di
più tipo era triste Non lo so però anche
questo va bene però è meraviglioso
perché c'eravamo messi d'accordo sembra
uno un numero di magia eravamo d'accordo
su questa cosa no ma ha sentito la
possibilità di parlare con me in questo
momento per me è surreale questa cosa
qui e la gente si apre in modo una volta
E dopo questa domanda E durante uno
spettacolo ho fatto un'altra domanda
che parlava con una ragazza che andava
in terapia e e le ho chiesto qual è
stato quel momento in cui tu hai detto
io andrò in Voglio andare in terapia
adesso e lei mi ha detto e dopo la morte
di mio
padre Esatto Questo è il Mood che si è
creato all'interno di uno spettacolo
comico quindi ha proprio sollevato gli
animi e io da grande professionista ho
deciso di uscirmene con Beh tu sì che
non vuoi diventare come tuo padre e
siamo andati avanti nel nel terrore nel
disagio e questa roba che per me è stato
veramente il regalo più grande che ho
ricevuto nella mia vita la possibilità
di connettermi con le persone a un certo
punto ha raggiunto un un picco un
piccolo punto di
rottura perché quando scavi così tanto e
ragioni sule cosine che ti rendono
insicuro e che ti rendono triste trovi
modi per renderle
divertenti a un certo punto lo
spettacolo finisce il tour finisce e tu
sei a casa da
solo senza nessuno che ride e lì devi
fare i conti col fatto che hai scavato
questa cosa è stata devastante ho
vissuto in un periodo abbastanza recente
e penso due mesi Di Stasi terribile e
nella quale avevo sanguinato troppo Ok
Avevo bisogno di leccarmi le ferite a
casa E questa cosa è stata molto pesante
per me per le persone che mi stanno
vicino
e ed è stato molto difficile uscirne da
questa cosa qui perché ero stato un
pochino troppo nell'altrove ed ero
approdato in un altro altrove che è
quello Invece della verità perché c'è
c'è una bellissima frase di Anna gby che
è una comica australiana che vi googlate
anche lei e che è il fatto che la la
standup Comedy si ferma alla punchline
ok
cioè introduzione svolgimento punchline
battuta sono andato indietro No
e la vita va oltre la punchline va
quello che succede cioè la vita è quello
che succede anche dopo la parte
divertente e quella roba lì è
agghiacciante Ma scusate per questo
metto un altro gattino se
volete Esatto così ci ritiriamo un po'
sugli
animi anche se era un po' più così in
quel periodo Quella è la mano della mia
ragazza che mi accarezzava la testa
mentre io dicevo Ahah non faccio più
ridere Questa cosa
così Il punto però Qual è che anche lì
esplorare il
malessere è l'unica roba che puoi fare
in una situazione del genere non puoi
scappar ne più non puoi fare altre
battute sull'argomento
e devo dire che per quanto sia stato
terrificante questo momento qui mi ha
dato la possibilità di imparare una roba
nuova Cioè il fatto che la condivisione
che io credevo possibile fino a quel
momento sulle cose brutte solo con 100
sconosciuti che poi non ti vedono a casa
in realtà può funzionare anche nell'uno
a uno che sembra una cosa molto molto
scontata ma per me non lo è stato per
niente ok perché io ero
così miim metto
l'ultima così
ok e è una roba che mi sono chiesto
molto in quel periodo lì è dove metti la
linea Dove metti la linea tra quello che
puoi dire agli sconosciuti e quello che
devi tenere per te perché è quello è
quella la fine la roba No Perché Poi
vedevo che questa cosa delle battute mi
disgregare i rapporti sociali giorno
dopo giorno perché ero in giro con gli
amici a un certo punto succede è una
cosa molto divertente e c'era questa
reazione di Ecco qui ora salvo parla
della mia prostatite di nuovo no questa
cosa qua e a un certo punto ho dovuto
imparare a mettere dei limiti a questa
cosa
e i
limiti sono stato sono state la cosa
cioè è stata la cosa che mi ha salvato
la vita
effettivamente perché bellissimo
sanguinare bellissimo dare il 100% per
ricevere il 100%
e Ma hai bisogno di tenere delle robe
per te quindi la linea c'è non c'è la
tracci tu io ho deciso dove tracciare la
mia
linea continuerò a condividere tutto
quello che
posso Avevo anche pensato una bellissima
battuta per per chiudere questo questo
speech ma ho deciso che la tengo per
me Grazie
mille
n